con loro fermi fermi fermi fermi non
aprite la porta seguito vero ma non
hanno ancora capito come sempre la forza
io scherzavo sala del piacere se
corriamo subito cerchi miss fiera tutta
non me l'aspettavo mai ma [ __ ]
devo tornare al quadro elettrico un
casino sto facendo non avete idea questo
casino per uscire perché no
porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ] via via via via
via posto a cosa porta cosa non c entri
in apporto sì non ci passi teoricamente
ci riguarda è arrivata come è possibile
tutto questo look guarda fuori dalla
finestra che senso 04 amici
07 04 porca [ __ ] ti sotto sorella
quella ben avevano ce ne sono due una
brutta ma anche l'altro forza ti
dicevano cose il gallo torna lo devo
fare fuori immagino non sono una che
visto dove è andato a matri cuore lo zio
sparito
bene porca [ __ ] mi sono scagliato
nelle mutande ma almeno non si vedono
ok a posto
finiamola qui non mi mandare altri come
quelli sì no no no ma che faccio sono
morto madonna quanto europa e bellissimo
trovare visti proiettili mamma mia oh
era ecco mi sono pagato in mano ed era
semplicemente il coso visore notturno
andate a cagare madonna che ansia non
l'avevo visto ma adesso si staccano ti
staccano cento per cento non si è
svegliato ne so quando ci ripasso di
nuovo si svegliano tutti ma sai che non
ho capito
porca put come strisce mi avete rotto le
palle e poi vostre giampiero quanti gas
siete miranda ci considera come dei
bambini cosa me ne frega a me niente
la risposta allora mi concede più che
dai lingua di età o scavate che non
fatemi spuntare qualcuno
no vi prego per passo
me lo chiedo per cortesia ve lo chiedo
per cortesia tiro
vabbè ho finito sono morto non riesco a
capire perché tu sia così mila cazzo è
successo
come non gliene frega
qualcosa ma poi non gliene è fregato
niente cene arrivato un proiettile se
guardate in giro come dire ma cosa che
mi appunto c'è il salvagente sulla gobba
si è visto che culo
dovrei esserci io non tu che stai
parlando
ma che schifo ma che schifo
madonna quando un machete così si mette
a ridere sul cazzo
io ve l'ho detto io ve l'ho detto ti
senti bene io avevo detto io ve l'ha
detto ovvero del dubbio il machete volo
recupererei è servito pregare ma ci si
augura tv questi secondi più giudizio
unico attimi di laporta chiudi la porta
la lazio si unì la porta via le api ma
cosa padre va via non è lui non è più
lascia lascio andare vai vai va bene va
bene ma vi lascia la lascia la chi se ne
frega perché miti ragazzi se notate
dall'inizio del gioco non c'è ogni cosa
che faccio finisce in merda mi hanno
crocifisso istanza non l'ho mai visto
nelle categorie di youtube
[Musica]
però si sa comoda ma come metto piede
sotto sono finito sono un uomo morto
defunto ecco
beh
io entrare qua dentro che male si mette
male perché chi c'è
mi piace uno grave no lui no
[Musica]